[Music]
that is the sixth turnover of the game
for ronanna here's a lot for Sharp two
hands many
41-22 off the feed from Nasir little
that's what we've been waiting to see
wow did he get up there here's the drive
swings out the coal he drives steps
through finger roll double clutch no and
the rebound is picked up by SAR under 50
seconds left now here's Johnson with the
drive to love for Sharp and he throws it
down and with that basket the McDonald's
won her Point play has been activated
you can score a free six-piece chicken
McNuggets tomorrow come here locally
owned and operated McDonald's be sure to
download the McDonald's app now 101.67
coach the final 44 minutes and that
Championship clinching game he also won
a national championship as a player at
Ohio State
had a great basketball career 86 years
old passed away yesterday
Dion Johnson down the lane
beautiful lob and there is the 19 year
old dropping the Hammer with the right
hand I told you he could jump out of the
gym
Portland defensively is really clogging
the lanes clogging the paint forcing the
king to kind of play outside of their
system right now but Darren had an
answer yeah they fell asleep defensively
none tries to go Baseline looks for
Reeves turns it over two on one the man
back is LeBron oh the love and the jam
and the Finish By sharp can get out and
run and Winslow sets it up perfectly
then throws it up and look at sharp
elevator throw it down
perfect pass and obviously you know one
thing that changed with the new
Tick-Tock train to Summers I mean they
always got something going on there I
don't know sharp on the drive
that was quick that's the second jump
defensively people just want to stay
glued to you because they are fearful
Grant slaps it outside air sharp the
other way coxson and rocks a right-hand
slam On The Run Grant working on things
a windmill Jackhammer for Satan sheriff
on a terrific setup that's why he was
the number seven pick in the draft
delayed reaction from the crowd the echo
reverberating here's a loose ball Keon
Johnson runs it down
surf was curling for the two-hand jam
[Applause]
against
Winslow gets a piece of that as it was
angled up to the rim and then little up
the floor up top there sharp to redirect
off the boots fingertips definitely done
their transition he knows who he's got
on that right wing
it doesn't matter if he's jumping off a
one foot or two Jaden gets high above
the win great pass
won't get that one got to release it
quickly yeah DeAndre knew it too yeah
on a high alert fast break sharp he's in
his last five threes Booker sneaking
inside came in too strong looked like
the room basket interference without a
doubt the lob inside to Shaden sharp
showing off his hops
[Applause]
pass across in traffic to sharp sharp
elevating are in the building tonight
two of the top eight Everest to play in
the NBA in the building oh my goodness
that's what I'm talking about Jaden
sharp
a lot of weapons fourth quarter becomes
a possession game
gonna grab that rebound
[Applause]
sharp kind of grab that rebound if you
don't strong closeout forcing Curry to
spin rebound a little out in front to
Grant
he will go to get it with a right hand
you gotta have the hotel key card to get
up to this floor right here you're not
just getting on the elevator you gotta
have the shading
atom Club
salivating at the one-on-one matchup
buyers
sharp just detonated
[Music]
with two hands and James Jones Johnson
came over to clip him great starts and
you see he's involved watch out
good Scoop pass from Trenton
to the rookie
goes up takes the hit across the head
doesn't face
[Applause]
parts of the basketball second turnover
on the Blazers Denver was six
oh there's no denying that dude Dave's
chest pass knocked down by Anderson
Lookout Hart recovers out there's sharp
taking it with a windmill action right
through the hole in the Blazers lead by
two now of course it'd be nice if the
three drops
so the play went on and now Satan's on
the base season all you got to do is put
it up in the air don't got to be close
to the ramp
they could be in the paint outside the
painting don't matter he'll grab it from
the shoulder level watch for the pass to
you Banks outside of Winslow fakes
drives it pushes one up off the glass no
Watford the recovery he'll drive it
inside there's an offensive
sharp he gets in the air without options
Watford bails him out gives to Simon to
trigger three no tipped by sharp right
to Watford surveys kicks Winslow hit one
earlier from there
sir sharp with a two-hand magic
[Applause]
it actually sent to Toronto and then
they waived him and Portland picked him
up
there is sharp I said on the receiving
end like I said when trading sharp is on
the floor don't go to grab anything he's
just effortless the way he floats off
the ground there's Devin
coming out and off the bat but what a
difference he helped these first ball
Club oh that's what I said sharp about
this I warned you about shade and sharp
I warned you you can't get up my
goodness and again uh he had a dunk 40
left in the third quarter Lucas favorite
spot does not produce a main three and
it's Watford with the ball and Watford
running
wow Shaden sharp is on the highlight
reel
and then milikina lost it
three on one Sharp
roll bomb with his ninth appearance this
is not just in Toyota Center this is
everywhere
sharp
Rockets come on a slido watching a
little bit there this is that's just a
phenomenal adjustment right there from
season to season
yeah this could be one of those nights
for clay
Warrior shooting it at 48 Portland at
49. Lillard shot that from three months
and Trent Watford and Jade on Sharp and
it's sharp soaring in to dunk that down
sharp this game is completely turned on
its head and Portland their biggest lead
of the night
five Blazer turnovers six Detroit points
off turnovers
wow gp2 throws a perfect lob to Shaden
sharp who nearly jumped out of the gym
replay nerk gets in sets the screen
that's all you need a little bit of a
brush because it's a guy guarded the
screener magley whose Gardener does not
drop in to help there is no help for
this plate
[Music]
pass to Rivers who makes the catch
Prince turns it over quickly ahead
Shaden sharp he's a high flyer
five-point game
[Applause]
Dion Johnson off the screen nice find
inside Greg Brown double team try to
reverse it get into the rim where
Watford could take it
giving a walker into the lane oh
beautiful pocket pass in there to Sharp
who cuts to the rack of the Dallas
Mavericks I mean see there they doubled
Dave got it out of his hands
in powering up to the rack oh there's a
meeting with only one guy's chairman of
the board
look at the hang time he moved it he
cabbage patched it and then he delivered
one of Michael Malone's goals to start
the season win the divisions and they're
well on their way to doing that Chris
Marlo Katie wengie Scott Hastings on
patrol and a law pass indeed to Shaden
sharp
sharpman bouncing back to shot they came
to double Dame and sharp was wide open
this is an addition to dunk you very
much
[Applause]
it's continuing to own the fast break
point category none more impressive than
that one it allowed one to break
to the human pogo stick some known as
Shake shot he'll be in the dunk
contested in Salt Lake City
showing the bottom of his shoes
far hurt asked me this question the
other night what dunk would you suggest
that this man take to Salt Lake City
what what dunk or two Michael is going
to catch the eye of the judges
I think he needs to take Lamar heard
Barnes with Hernan Gomez on the floor
the pass outside tip control and a
hammer thrown down by Shane sharp little
guys are feisty here goes shading
jumping the route
and he sees Bruce behind him
just wanted a really cool things about
six hurry straight arms to gaining
Advantage dirt seals off capella that
allows Hart to get in there for the
board sends it up top there's another
great lob On Target Atlanta Hawks
59-51
hey 19.
gp2 there's that live drum with
Precision to Sharp along the Baseline
nobody tracking and here's DBT
kind of had that ball up high let it
hang a little bit looks like he's going
to throw it out to the three-point line
on the left Jaden sees his man
he's a .5 man basically but this time he
turned it over right to gp2 Dave never
swapped in slops it up top there sharp
with a two-hand Jam
game giving the people what they want
this on the night already
foreign
just do it here
put a home crowd
[Music]
try to run this down as low as they can
Watford
there is Satan sharp
to Griffith and rip it out of the air
he'll just seize it and slam it tied the
game at 95.
trying to play not in the middle he
jumped and then he pulls he stopped for
a second to wait for the ball to get to
him
thank you
oh 10 points pass Diamond's near Center
Court holds Ottawa in front of Williams
and the screen comes from Trenton bounce
pass back to Walker to the picket yeah
another look at that alley-oop
trending's got numbers because Anthony
draws the additional attention
[Applause]
the UFO is on the break
cocked it back hammered it home Blazers
by 25.
[Applause]
James slows it down as he gets the
screen bounce past a sharp but he
hammers it in
[Applause]
Gibson up too high
understandably so because Dame's coming
off the pick he doesn't want to give him
space
Walker finally sees Nas now to sharpen
the corner let's go let's go
[Applause]
back and hammers it down
Shane sharp hammers it down
the Blazers Trail by 23 going forward on
the floor it's a successful three
[Music]
[Applause]
Blazers need the All-Star break as much
as anybody
[Music]
sharp cutting drives and hammers it in
he says hey I'm not going to be in the
slam dunk contest so let's have one
right now